One of the most mysterious and unexplored
areas left on this planet is the ocean floor.
We know next to nothing about it.
We don’t know what’s down there, what
creatures lurk in its depths or even what
it looks like.
But gravity might be able to lend us a hand.
Hey Guys Julia here for DNews
Scientists recently used what’s called “gravity
mapping” to map the ocean floor.
And just like that sounds, it’s when satellites
measure gravity to tell the topography of
a place.
In a study published in the journal Science
researchers merged data from two satellites
to reveal the underwater map.
The satellites, CryoSat-2 and Jason-1, measured
the distance from their location in space
to the surface of the land or water on Earth.
After filtering out the noise from waves and
other temporary changes in the ocean surface,
the satellites found certain areas in the
ocean with more gravity than others.
That’s because the mass of a mountain under
the ocean has more gravitational pull than
the water around it.
So the water kind of piles up on top of the
mountain and creates different heights on
the surface of the water.
A lower area has less gravity than a higher
area, because there is less mass.
Using these changes in gravity, scientists
could measure the seafloor by measuring the
surface of the ocean.
The results confirmed some previous data on
the bottom of the ocean and found some new
discoveries too.
In a study published in the journal Earth
and Planetary Science Letters, researchers
announced the discovery of a tiny new tectonic
plate called Mammerickx Microplate’.
While most tectonic plates are huge, like
thousands of kilometers across.
This little guy is just 150 km across, about
half the size of England.
While tiny, it broke off a much bigger plate
when the Indian plate and Eurasian plate crashed
into each other about 47 million years ago.
This map reveals how little we know about
the world around us.
We've only mapped 0.05 percent of the ocean
floor to our highest level of resolution with
sonar.
Most recently, we're using gravity mapping,
but 2,000 years ago guys were just throwing
measured ropes into the ocean with weights
on the ends.
There's still a lot we don't know.
We do know gravity isn’t equally distributed
around our planet.
How much gravity you experience at a specific
point on the surface can change.
Because Earth is more oblong than spherical,
it’s not equally dense, and the distance
from the center of the Earth to where you
stand can vary gravity's pull on you.
Knowing all this, gravitational mapping has
helped reveal new information about our planet.
Like a study published in the journal Geophysical
Research Letters found that the lowest acceleration
due to gravity is on Mount Nevado WASS CAR
ANNE Huascarán in Peru while the highest
is in the Arctic Ocean.
As New Scientist puts it, “if you fell from
a height of 100 metres, you would hit the
surface in Peru about 16 milliseconds later
than in the Arctic”.
Weird, right?
So why do we care?
Besides the whole weighing less on a mountain
in Peru thing?
Well it’s helpful for building things, engineers
need to know the local gravity layout when
designing buildings and infrastructure and
OF COURSE MEASURING GRAVITY IS AWESOME JUST
FOR A BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF THE BOTTOM OF
THE OCEAN.
Maybe we’ll finally know exactly what our
home planet looks like.
The oceans take up over 70% of this planet’s
surface, yet we know so little about them.
Trace fills you in on all the bottomless details
we know over on testtube plus.
Question So map nerds out there, what's your
favorite image or map of our pale blue dot?
Let me know down in the comments below